Trascrizione: Beatrice Vecchiato
Revisore: Anna M
[Musica]
Molti di voi si staranno chiedendo
che cosa c'è in questa scatola.
Bene.
Quello che c'è in questa scatola
lo scopriremo alla fine.
Ora vorrei partire con cosa
c'è fuori dalla scatola
Thinking out of the box.
Però per introdurre un argomento
sul pensiero laterale della percezione
devo a iniziare a testare
come siete messi.
Ok?
La prima cosa che vedremo
sul pensiero laterale
è la percezione.
E la percezione è molto importante
perché ci permette di partire
da un obiettivo.
Facciamo un esperimento insieme:
vi chiedo di alzarvi tutti
e ora vediamo il cambio di percezione.
Vi chiedo alla persona a fianco,
quando vi darò il via vi presenterete
come se incontraste un vecchio amico
che non incontrate da 20 anni.
Via!
Ok.
Ok, molto bene.
Adesso cambiamo la persona
e ci presentiamo
come se incontrassimo la persona
più famosa e importante
che vorremo incontrare nella nostra vita.
Che tipo di impatto sarebbe?
Benissimo.
E adesso vorrei lanciarvi una sfida,
vediamo quanto siete in grado.
Edward De Bono usa una tecnica
che si chiama "provocative operation",
PO.
La mia provocative operation adesso è:
iniziamo dalla fine.
Vorrei - quando darò il via -
che facciate l'applauso di conclusione
del mio discorso
come se aveste partecipato
al miglior discorso
con Edward De Bono
e i più grandi pensatori. 1,2,3 Vai!
(Applausi)
Troppo buoni.
Ok, grazie, grazie.
Adesso vi invito a sedervi
e cerchiamo di guadagnare
almeno una parte di quest'applauso.
Il punto centrale del pensiero laterale
De Bono dice:
"Poco eccitante parlare del focus,
dell'obiettivo su cui vogliamo
tenere creatività,
ma è molto importante."
Ad esempio, alla NASA
avevano bisogno di una penna
che fosse in grado di scrivere
in assenza di gravità.
Questa cosa chiaramente è un problema.
Pensate agli astronauti
che vanno nello spazio.
E allora hanno investito decine
di milioni di dollari
per costruire una penna che era
in grado di scrivere
con differenti inclinazioni.
Ad un certo punto in Russia
avevano lo stesso problema.
Ma che cos'hanno fatto?
Hanno cambiato il focus e hanno detto:
"In che modo posso scrivere
nello spazio senza gravità?"
Hanno usato una matita.
Per cui il cambio di obiettivo
spesso è già generativo di creatività.
E questo è un primo punto.
In realtà, le donne qui presenti
che convivono con un maschietto
sanno che una della cose più difficili
da far cambiare ad un uomo
è fare in modo che c'entri
esattamente il buco nell'asse.
Ok, e cos'hanno inventato negli autogrill?
Hanno inventato una mosca da mettere lì
così i maschietti quando arrivano
con il loro idrante
indirizzano l'obiettivo,
e guarda caso sono diminuite
le quantità di "strabordamenti"
perché il focus era orientato.
Invece di dire "Falla dentro, tuute le regole, ecc",
cambiare il focus.
Per cui il primo punto è il focus.
Il secondo punto è il pensiero laterale.
De Bono ha formalizzato
il pensiero laterale
e l'ha formalizzato
partendo da un presupposto:
il cervello non è fatto
per essere creativo.
E buona parte dei presenti dicono:
"Wow! Allora sono nel posto giusto"
Il cervello è fatto per cercare
schemi che funzionano. Ok?
Se adesso faccio ta-ta-ra-ta-ta-ta-ta?
Perché il cervello chiude gli schemi.
Quando imparo a guidare l'automobile
ci metto un po'
e poi ho degli automatismi
che mi permettono poi
di non sbagliare più.
A qualcuno sarà capitato invece
di cambiare l'auto
dal cambio manuale a quello automatico
e il primo momento è stato un po' un problema.
Per cui, gli schemi ci servono,
fanno risparmiare al cervello
un quantità di energia pazzesca.
Ma per la creatività dobbiamo
uscire dagli schemi.
E per uscire De Bono dice:
"Per stimolare il pensiero laterale,
dobbiamo usare degli stimoli
che permettano di uscire dallo schema."
Questa formalizzazione però è importante:
non è "crazyness", la follia.
È usare uno stimolo esterno,
che ci faccia uscire dal pensiero lineare
ma che poi dà un'idea logica posteriore.
Ad esempio, De Bono fa un esempio
per far capire:
nel mondo della creatività,
non dobbiamo pensare tanto
alla competizione con la altre aziende
e le altre organizzazioni.
Lui dice: dobbiamo pensare
alla "surpetizione".
Cioè fare gara a sé.
E per fare questo, siccome
ha trovato delle correlazioni
tra umorismo e creatività,
racconta una storiella.
Ci sono due amici,
uno un saputello, tutto preparato, perfettino,
e l'altro è un po' più spartano, più - diciamo - alla mano.
Stanno camminando in montagna
e ad un certo punto incontrano un grizzly.
Il grizzly è molto pericoloso per l'uomo,
perché è in grado con un zampata
di ucciderlo.
E purtroppo il grizzly
inizia a correre verso di loro.
A quel punto il saputello dice:
"Arriva il grizzly, non possiamo correre
più veloce del grizzly, siam finiti."
Quello meno saputello si piega,
inizia a togliere gli scarponcini,
tira fuori dallo zaino le scarpe da tennis
e inizia a mettere le scarpe da tennis.
L'amico lo guarda e gli dice:
"Guarda, il grizzly corre a 60 km all'ora,
tu uomo al massimo 35/40,
al massimo guadagnerai 2 o 3 metri
prima che ti prenda."
E lui dice:
"Ma a me non interessa correre
più veloce del grizzly,
ma più veloce di te."
Il cambio di prospettiva
e il pensiero laterale
fanno diventare logica posteriore
una soluzione.
Tante volte ci è capitato
di trovare una soluzione
che a posteriori abbiamo pensato:
"Che stupido, non me n'ero accorto"
Ecco, questo è usare degli strumenti
per forzare la mente a uscire dagli schemi
perché non è creativo.
Ma purtroppo il pensiero laterale
non basta.
Anche i colleghi precedenti hanno detto
non solo dei due emisferi
ma che la creatività
è qualcosa di completo.
Infatti io stesso molti anni fa
ho coniato un termine: creattività.
Che è, andare oltre alla semplice creatività
e nello specifico il pensiero parallelo.
Personalmente De Bono è famoso
per il pensiero laterale
e questo è il construtto più importante
che lui ci ha donato.
Nello specifico lui dice:
(mi ha raccontato questa storia
che poi non ha più raccontato negli ultimi 20 anni
per cui la socializzo con voi,
però lui non la racconta più)
Come funziona il cervello.
Lui dice: i pescatori dei paesi tropicali
hanno scoperto che l'ostrica crea la perla
e la perla e la ostrica più è naturale
più ha valore.
E hanno scoperto che legandole
tutte insieme e buttandole in acqua
l'ostrica fa il suo tempo e cresce.
Ma la cosa interessante, pensate,
tornano dopo un anno
ostriche e molluschi
si possono muovere di un metro o due,
per cui potrebbe essere
a 300 o 400 metri di distanza
E cosa accade?
Le ostriche sono a 2 o 3 metri
da dove le han lasciate.
Secondo voi cos'è successo?
È semplice: essendo tutte legate,
una tira di qui, una tira di là,
l'altra tira di quì,
e si rimane esattamente fermi.
Questo è quello che De Bono
ha formalizzato
sul pensiero tra gli esseri umani.
Tra gli esseri umani c'è quello
che cerca di essere creativo,
quello che cerca di essere analitico,
quello che cerca di valutare un'idea.
Se cerco di fare tutto insieme,
quello che io ottengo
è bloccare la creatività
e l'innovazione del gruppo. Ok?
Non faccio riferimenti a contesti politici
che non si possono fare,
ma è un bellissimo esempio
di "ostricamento", di non riuscire a muoversi. Ok?
Andiamo avanti con un'applicazione
di questo concetto che è:
la creatività in realtà è solo
uno stile di pensiero,
ma ce ne sono almeno altri nove
che ci aiutano per realizzare le cose.
Thomas Edison diceva:
la creatività è 1% ispirazione,
99% traspirazione.
Fare le cose. Imparare.
E questo è un punto molto importante:
perché qui noi stiamo condividendo
moltissime idee,
ma le idee da sole sono passive,
dobbiamo farle diventare attive.
E per questo approfondirò
4 o 5 schemi di pensiero
che possono aiutarci
a realizzare le nostre idee.
Il primo punto è legato alla capacità
di saper cogliere le idee.
Tutti noi vorremmo essere più creativi? No.
E io vi dico:
"No, lasciate perdere,
non diventate più creativi.
Fate come Steve Jobs.
Steve Jobs non era creativo.
Steve Jobs non era un informatico.
Steve Jobs è famoso per aver
rubato idee un po' a tutti.
Vi faccio degli esempi.
Primo: le interfacce grafiche.
Andò in visita alla Xerox Parc
che facevano fotocopiatrici,
vide le interfacce grafiche e chiese:
"Scusi, che ci fate
con queste interfacce grafiche?"
Loro dissero: "Noi siamo un'azienda
che fa fotocopie, non facciamo computer,
per cui, non lo so, ci serve per questo."
Lui prese l'idea, esagerò,
prese anche il direttore Ricerca e Sviluppo,
lo portò in Apple e implementò quest'idea.
La seconda idea, un capolavoro.
Devono lanciare un prodotto,
lanciano l'IPod.
L'IPod era un brevetto scaduto
che lui ha preso da un ragazzotto
che aveva fatto a vent'anni,
(che purtroppo "non ha preso una lira"
perché non aveva i soldi per pagare il brevetto).
E lo ha lanciato sul mercato lui.
Cogliere il valore delle idee.
Io ho creato un database di idee,
ho più di un migliaio di idee
raccolte in tutto il mondo
di successi imprenditoriali di marketing
ed è impressionante quante idee ci sono.
Per cui prendiamo le idee dagli altri
e miglioriamole.
Secondo punto è:
come motivare la creatività.
Molto più importante:
il fuoco, il perché.
E questo è fondamentale.
Non tanto avere idee.
Io dico: un buon perché vale mille come.
Diamo un buon motivo.
C'è una storia divertente: Apollo 13.
Il film: un signore lo affitta
da BlockBuster.
C'è un'azienda fallita
che si chiamava BlockBuster.
Affitta il video, tutto contento,
e si dimentica del video,
come capita a tutti noi.
Dopo 60 giorni lo riporta,
e gli danno 30 dollari di multa.
Si inviperisce e dice:
"Faccio qualcosa di diverso
per fargliela vedere a questi fetenti".
E crea Netflix.
Netflix è nata così. Per la rabbia.
Molto spesso la motivazione:
"rabbia, invidia, odio, passione, amore"
sono le chiavi di successo.
E noi abbiamo spessissimo
l'imprenditore o l'inventore
-sono due personaggi
che la motivazione li smuove-
Perché ci interessa questa parte?
Perché per realizzare qualcosa,
sia da inventore che da imprenditore..
Pensate che Dyson,
quello che ha inventato l'aspirapolvere,
ha fatto 5000 prototipi
che non funzionavano.
Accettare 5000 fallimenti
è notevole.
Thomas Edison,
il suo collaboratore gli disse:
"Thomas, (quando dovevano inventare
la lampadina)
Abbiamo fatto 10000 fallimenti,
molliamo il colpo".
E lui risponse:
"Non abbiamo fatto 10000 fallimenti,
sappiamo 10000 modi
di come non si fa una lampadina". Ok?
La frustrazione dell'insuccesso
è molto legata alla motivazione.
Per cui se io ho la passione,
riesco a combattere e a imparare
e a non farmi scoraggiare
da questi elementi.
E ancora di più:
se io sono molto creativo
e un altro è molto organizzato,
è inutile che io investa tanto tempo
ad imparare ad essere più organizzato.
Non ce la faccio.
Le mie brain dominance sono troppo forti.
Per cui la storia ci insegna:
alleanze di cervelli.
Fate un'alleanza di cervelli di persone
che sono complementari a voi.
La pensino magari valorialmente insieme,
ma le complementarietà,
la storia dei successi è data
da tantissime persone
che avevano stili complementari.
E insieme a questa parte
c'è la comunicazione dell'idea,
è molto importante
saper comunicare un'idea.
Alla NASA si dice:
"Se io ho una banana e tu hai una banana,
ci scambiamo la banana,
e alla fine ognuno di noi
andrà via con una banana.
Ma se io ho un'idea e tu hai un'idea,
quando andremo via,
avremo entrambi due idee."
Per cui, condividere senza aver paura
di farsi rubare le idee,
particolarmente con la nostra
alleanza di cervelli.
Molti successi imprenditoriali o di idee
sono stati su come le ho comunicate
e le ho sapute, diciamo,
"fare il marketing dell'idea".
Ho iniziato 10 anni fa
con Philippe Kotler e De Bono
un progetto che si chiama "Markethink"
che è: "Come avere creatività
per vendere le idee".
Conta molto di più saperle vendere.
E ora siamo arrivati a svelare la domanda:
che cosa abbiamo nella scatola?
Ora, chi indovina può mangia...
No no (risata)
Che cosa abbiamo nella scatola?
Quello che abbiamo nella scatola
è l'ultimo punto con cui vi lascio
che è molto importante
come stile di pensiero.
I creativi spesso ne pensano mille,
ma non ne fanno.
Il punto importante è il pensiero pratico,
rendere concreta l'idea che volete fare
e imparare sbagliando.
E per farvelo meglio capire
aprirò la scatola e tirerò fuori questa:
una lampadina, dell'idea.
Ma per farvelo capire ancora meglio
che dovete agire e non solo pensare,
vi invito adesso tutti quanti
ad alzare il culo, ma concretamente
perché sotto la vostra sedia
ne ho messa una per voi in omaggio.
(Fatelo.)
E questa è l'idea, un antistress.
L'obiettivo che vi chiedo sarà questo:
fra poco avremo la pausa,
e quando sarete insieme
condividete le vostre idee,
le vostre passioni,
e create le vostre alleanze di cervello.
Grazie.
[Applausi]